ha got it you got it yeah still reserved
do it oh it's got like it's been here
for a while I'm Devon and I've never
done a pickup in LA before but I'm
excited I guess we're gonna be logging
some garbage
I'm Elbert I'm from LA and I'm happy to
be part of this cleanup as it's
important for me to keep my city clean I
really care about plastic pollution and
I really want to reduce it because I
grew up on beaches and I've just seen
enough of it I'm tired of it and I'm
really excited to be a part of the
initiatives that are correcting that
what are we gonna be doing here today so
today we're here to not just pick up
trash but we're gonna be cataloguing the
types of materials and brands associated
with every piece of trash that we're
finding out here we're trying to get
really specific data that we can take
back to legislators to businesses to the
people who are making the decisions to
reduce plastic pollution at the source
and stop it from ever making its way out
into the ocean what is the actual
process well one thing we've done is
we've developed a really cool web app
that allows people to track all of that
as they go along it's able to catalog
the type of material a product is even
if it's not plastic so for example if
I'm finding a plastic straw and it's
green and I know that straw comes from
Starbucks I'm gonna log one straw
Starbucks and that's available for each
item once we're done collecting that
data it gives us an overview of what we
found including brand and type of
material we're gonna give you bags for
the cleanup a one glove one of you will
be collecting trash in your bags and the
other one will be collecting the data
through the app well it's all pretty
straightforward
look at the Turtles wow they have
turtles here they're protecting them
from straws and other plastics big bad
straws all right let's get started go
for it I already see something newspaper
this can be recycled at least people
would produce a newspaper little cap
Miller High Life so a beer cap there's a
piece this looks like a chocolate
wrapper Ghirardelli caramel got one just
put cereal so I was just going to
plastic right then done
plastic straw wrapper
look packaging straws material plastic I
see a Starbucks stick guy here Oh
straight up calling up Starbucks right
now got the mermaid and everything
another little straw guy straw wrapper
plus the candy wrapper oh no straw
wrapper again Starbuck straw wrapper
Starbucks is everywhere looks like
somebody just missed the trashcan or
maybe it fell down the side when they
threw it yep it's a Gatorade caputo
napkin the saw legs right here - some
napkins oh yeah more napkins I got lots
of napkins down there another nap eat
lots of just roll up napkins swisher
Sweets Oh some kind of cigar wrapper it
looks like it's a buckle packaging wrap
plastic and one alright gosh then we
have this little fruit cup it doesn't
have any binding there Oh the brand I
can't see score I think that's a candy
yet work yeah sko our candy wrapper
didn't even know these still existed
suanne buds write you a whole little
trio a mysterious dropper thing it's
like eye drops me is it maybe it's a tie
Jonathan oh I see another Gatorade cap a
little Hennessy ball is it plastic or
glass yeah oh there's a bottle down
there but I don't want to fall into the
water
alright that's the nature let's do it
let's do it
little heroes wear capes little bottle
please keep your plastic out of our
lakes what is that
oka halt oh I see a can down there too
for nature let's go and we get this out
of the way ah got it you got it yeah
still reserved do it oh it's got like
it's been here for a while seeing
treasure this actually did get me
considering changing some options on my
life maybe with like contribute less to
waste and actually get that reusable
Starbucks cup thing all this trash it
does make me want to try a little harder
maybe even do more of these pickups
yeah I definitely feel like I just want
to gather more reusable things and just
actually put them to use instead of
forget about them
[Music]